hello guys and welcome to a video
regarding the kenobi tv show so we've
been given some new information
regarding hayden christensen's darth
raider via the form of an interview we
also have some images to go with this
now i know these images are old and you
guys have probably seen them before so
that's why i won't really break them
down too much and just get into the
interview stuff but nevertheless i'll
play the new images in the background
just in case you haven't seen this new
look at the show so when hayden was
asked about um how it felt to put the
suit back on he said well without
getting into too much detail it was
amazing it's a great honor to get to put
that suit on then he went on to describe
his role in kenobi it was mostly a lot
of excitement because i had spent enough
time with this character and i felt like
i knew him and coming back to it felt
very natural in a lot of ways and i was
just really excited to get to come in
and play darth vader at this point in
the timeline because i did feel like a
natural continuation of the journey with
the character and that was very
meaningful for me the whole experience
was very surreal just the nature of
coming back after all this time it's
such a unique opportunity one that both
you and i were very grateful for one of
the things i loved so much about working
on star wars projects is just that
shared excitement that everyone's real
excited to be there you can feel that
energy and that's a really special thing
he concluded by saying i don't know what
i can say in terms of behind the scenes
type stuff because i don't think they
want me saying too much but i can tell
you the first time that i saw ewin as
obi-wan again that was a very special
moment for me and one that i remember
for a very very long time also the
series rider when asked about how much
we can expect vader in the show he went
on to say his shadow is cast across so
much of what we do and the degree of his
proximity to that shadow is something
that we'll discover but he is very much
a part of the show emotionally for
obi-wan and possibly beyond that as well
so obviously the series rider here is
teasing another confrontation between
vader and obi-wan do you think my memory
serves me correctly that kathleen
kennedy also mentioned that raider and
kenobi will have the greatest rematch of
the century so i think it's safe to say
that we'll see darth vader and obi-wan
battle it out once again after they're
joined mustafa and i got to say this
image here of darth raider from the
kenobi show it looks very very
reminiscent of that very iconic shot we
see of him in empire strikes back and i
gotta say it's looking fantastic and
it's so good to see vader on the screen
once again and i cannot wait to see him
in the show also if you guys haven't
heard already the release date for
obi-wan kenobi has been pushed back
until may the 27th although you may be
disappointed by this they are now
releasing two episodes on this day so
instead of just getting one episode
released on the wednesday we'll be now
getting two episodes on the friday so i
think this is a surprise to be sure but
a welcome one anyway guys let me know in
the comment section below if you're
excited to see darth raider in the
kenobi tv show if you haven't already
please like and subscribe and turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching